professor on what prompted your interest
in forensic anthropology was it a TV
show
was it witnessing something at a museum
what started it was very simple I wanted
to be an anthropologist because I loved
bones it's that simple
I also studied I also cross trained Enzo
archaeology which is animal more remains
so formal I loved bones my license plate
says into bones so I went to school to
study bones when I got there I met my
professor who I ended up being her
research assistant and all that fun
stuff she was a forensic anthropologist
number 52 out of I think there's like 60
something now only board-certified and
she introduced me to the world of
forensic anthropology okay got it
another caveat for you
forensic means of the courts it just
means that we're doing things for the
people by the people of the people type
of thing I was on the forensics squad in
college and that was the Speech and
Debate team so forensics everybody goes
are you into forensics actually what
you're really saying is are you into
science
it's the Forensic Sciences that is
actually what we're talking about here
forensics is just the moniker but that
just means that you're going to court
for it there's forensic nurses that will
talk about rape kits there's forensic
accountants that will talk about doubl
books and stuff like that because that's
still illegal it if anything if it's
illegal or a criminal or even a civil
act it could be it could be considered
forensics so I'll get off my high horse
on that one
you